سناتور أنت تترأس لجنة الكونغرس
التي تشرف على التنصيب ،
لديك الكثير من الوظائف
أم ما هي التعديلات التي ستجريها
على الافتتاح بسبب
الوباء ، هل ستطلب أقنعة ،
نعم أعتقد أننا سوف أه دان أعتقد أننا
نأمل  أن أكون بالخارج مرة أخرى على الجبهة الغربية ،
لكنني أعتقد أننا لن نرى ما يقرب من
العديد من الأشخاص سواء
على المنصة أو هناك في الفضاء
حيث يدخل الأشخاص إلى الفضاء الآمن
الذي
يحتوي على تذكرة أه ليكون في الجبهة الغربية
أه
و  بالعودة إلى مناقشتنا السابقة ،
تعلمون أن لدي هذه الوظيفة لدي وظيفة
عد الأصوات الانتخابية ، أتمنى أن
يكون الرئيس هناك
أه في يوم الافتتاح واه مستمر
في العمل لنرى ما يمكننا القيام به ليكون
لدينا رئيس هناك و
من المحتمل أن يؤدي نائب الرئيس بايدن
اليمين في ذلك اليوم ،
أه حسنًا ، قلت إنك تأمل أن
يكون هناك ، أعني أنه ليس هناك ما يشير
إلى أنه سيذهب ، هل تجري
محادثات معه تحاول أن
تدفعه للقيام بذلك
لا ولكن  لقد شجعت بالتأكيد
موظفيه على النظر في الانتقال الآن ، انظر
إلى الفرصة في جورجيا لمساعدتنا في
الفوز بمقاعد مجلس الشيوخ هذه ، انظر إلى ما
يمكن أن يفعله الرئيس إذا كان الرئيس يغادر
البيت الأبيض كما يقول إنه سيفعل إذا
يخسر تصويت الهيئة
الانتخابية لمساعدتنا على استعادة المنزل في عام
2022 وأعتقد أن هناك دورًا كبيرًا للرئيس
ترامب وأتمنى أن يحتضن ذلك أه وإه
ينظر إلى كيف تنتقل إلى أي شيء
يأتي بعد ذلك
بالنسبة له على افتراض أن هذا  الانتخابات
تسير بالطريقة التي يبدو أنها ستفعل